anthony diesel fought he allowed a
couple of base runners in the first but
escaped dom smith leads off
belt
diesel finally covering
and he corralled that kind of a high
throw from belt
but they get the out one away
so one out here's vr
it's a walk for vr after that last pitch
for ball four to vr there was something
the giants dugout and dave greshner the
giants trainer and manager gabe kepler
came out to visit with dee schlafani you
watch when he went over and covered
there was a little bit of a hitch in his
right leg and wow this is an unexpected
turn of events he's going to leave the
game the word on anthony d sclafani is
that he left with right ankle discomfort
jose alvarez is on the pitch now in
relief of anthony d stefani and he's
kind of picked off
wow now that's a pick off yeah that's a
pick off right there
when you completely bat walk the guy at
first base to where he can't even move
you've made a great pick off two down
nobody on
struck him out ending over no score
brandon crawford will bat
in the air toward the left field line
smith a long run davis going out smith
coming in sliding he makes the catch
dominic smith had allowed the ground to
cover toward the left field line on that
floater off the bat of crawford and
smith making a sliding grab just before
the foul line to take a base it away two
up two down fastball hit in the air deep
left center nimo's back forward he's at
the warning track he slows down makes
the catch one two three inning for
mcgill tyler mcgill will face the bottom
three in the giants order swung on and
missed change up and a good one from
tyler mcgill it's been a good pitch for
him this year
that's down the left-hand line
dom smith cuts it off
dickerson's gonna test him no
after a 40-foot round of first base he
put the brakes on and race back to first
that's the first hit for the giants
against mcgill so here's the former matt
wilmer flores
bay's head to left field but dickerson
started to go back to second on that
liner so he was ultra cautious but it
does set up a first and third one out
now for the top of the lineup he drives
one down the left field line slicing
into the corner a fair ball
it stays in play dickerson scores
wilmer the third a double for lamont way
junior one-nothing giants
lamont way junior i mean he hesitated
coming out of the box i think i think he
thought it was gonna slice foul runners
at second and third one run in bryant
struck out his first time
one two coming struck him out with the
slider good pitch by mcgill to get brian
the giants won the match nothing it will
be jake mcgee a power pitcher and pete
alonso a power hitter to lead off
against him it hit him
alonso hit
on the left arm he has doubled over in
pain right now
he does wear some padding over his left
elbow hard to tell exactly where that
pitch got him but he's favoring that
left arm as he walks up the first base
line got him on the elbow guard but it
still appeared
to create a lot of pain so he's the
tying one at first good four to the
batter they do not put the shift on
against michael and he pulls one on the
ground off the middle base head alonzo
turns second he'll go on to third
yastromski's throw goes to second and
the mets have the table set first and
third and nobody out the mets have the
tying run 90 feet away with nobody out
here in the ninth inning jd davis the
batter now
fly ball out to right field tagging at
third alonso you stretch he's got a good
arm here comes alonzo here comes the
throw not in time and the mets tie the
game
jd davis delivers the tying one with a
sacrifice fly alonzo sore elbow and all
comes home with the tying run and the
mets score in the ninth to tie into the
one now the batter dominic smith
toward the middle
crawford shoves it right from the glove
to bryant cover wow there's no way
crawford
goes on a spear and how's he gonna get
it he glove flips it over to la stella
and they get the force and immediately
this play starts going into the mvp
chant and that is an mvp type play and
that's a shot in the arm for mcgee that
play now vr
strike three called right down the
middle but the mets have tied it well
pete alonso's come out of the game after
getting whacked on the elbow by a pitch
he scored the tying run but he's out now
dom smith moves to first kevin pillar
comes in to play left and edwin diaz
will pitch the bottom of the ninth diaz
will retire the first two in the ninth
two-two coming struck him out
diaz fans yostremski a seven-pitch
inning for diaz and we're going to extra
innings and for the giants tony watson
comes into the game now and he of course
will have to inherit that automatic
runner at second base and that would be
jonathan vr the mets one of their
fastest runners
the bunt watson's got it over to bryant
the tag and he's out and it wasn't that
close
tony watson could not have played that
any better you throw you have a lean
towards the right side you react to the
to the ball it's just too much steam on
it a perfect strike to bryant who puts
on the tag that is huge in this
situation now with the runner at first
base and one out
that one has hit well deep into left
field
way back there it is
for the leaping lamont way junior
two down wow
another great defensive play and wade
who played most of this afternoon or
right field swings over to left field
gets a very difficult play he goes back
goes high up to get it then it's an
awkward tilt into the fence great
concentration on the play he did not let
the fence affect the way he made that
catch two on two out
lestella
he trapped it against his midsection
inning over first and third and one out
and now evan longoria will come up as a
pinch hitter 2-2 to longoria
popped it up on the infield
mcneal waiting for it
two out
huge out for edwin diaz as he gets
longoria to pop off back to the top of
the lineup and lamont wade jr
and wade pops one up
shallow left
pilar on the line makes the catch in
foul territory and we will go to the
11th inning tyler chatwood who has
bounced around baseball he was with
toronto now with the giants forto had a
base hit in the ninth to help build the
mets only run of the game
2-2
breaking ball drilled to right field
base in the mets will take the lead it
goes back to the wall mcneil scores
conform in the second he slides in
safely with an rbi double and the mitch
lead it 2-1 in the 11th conforto drives
in his 30th run of the year and none
bigger to put the mets in front in the
11. jerry's familia will bid for his
second save of the year the wade the
free runner is the tying run at second
tommy the stella will be the first man
up
base head to right field
wade rounds third he'll score easily
conforto throws towards second
tommy lestella's first hit of the day
in the clutch tied up that is a money
swing of the bat and it was rifled
through the infield and la stella says i
got this so they waited till 2-0 and now
they'll give crawford the intentional
walk and a pitch to mike ustremski
instead swing it a bit strike three
yestrenski strikes out in a fastball and
jerry's familia keeps it tied dom
smith's your runner at second base and
jonathan vr up to face chatwood
again he pulls it back slashes at the
left field that is a fair ball
picked up by wade smith comes in to
score and the mets go back in front
ball hit right near the chalk down the
left field line jonathan villard drives
in the go ahead running the mets laid
three to two in the 12th oh
that might be foul ronnie yes
they're going to overturn this call
oh my
less than an inch gary and that's what
they got
wow chat one of the giants they get a
do-over
struck him out
oh that's a great slider right there and
the mets have runners at the corners
with one out so now the mets are a fly
ball away from regaining the lead with
kevin pillar coming up
and pilar hits a rocket out to left
field back goes way to the warning track
back at the wall it's out of here
kevin pillar with a three-run homer
pilar back in san francisco almost hit
one his last time up this time he makes
no mistake pillar with a bomb to put the
mets in front in the 12th inning number
10 for pilar and it's 5-2 new york
what a big hit for kevin pillar a
two-out double for jeff mcneil and now
chance cisco will make his mets debut
and cisco drives one toward the right
field corner that's a base hit and
that'll chase so mcneal chance cisco on
the first pitch he sees as a met with an
rbi double in the top of the 12th to
make it 6-2 welcome to the club
and now the giants are down to their
final out and the pitcher tyler chatwood
is going to have to take the turn it
back now reed tried to close it down
he struck him out and the ball game is
over and on a day the mets were called
out by their owner their offense arrived
late and the mets snap a five-game
losing streak with a much needed six 6-2
12-inning victory over the giants